hello here it's this guy kaufmann I
continue my series on the seven secrets
of language learning
we remember that the first secret
yields was to spend the time
enough time to succeed
in learning a language
second thing was to do
pleasant things things that we
like
third thing is to develop the
ability to notice what is
happening in the moor to pay attention to
what is happening in our languages ​​good
fourth secret  it's that the
vocabulary is more important than the
grammar why because there are
several reasons first of all if you have
if you master the grammar but
you have you don't have many
people you won't understand what the person is
saying  other the native and you have you are
going to have a lot of difficulty
explaining express their
thoughts because it takes words it
takes a lot of people but secondly
it is very difficult to learn the
grammar to understand the grammar if
you don't have a point of reference
so you start with the costs of
reading accumulated words to develop your
understanding of the language and your
experience with the moor and it is after
that that the explanations of  grammar
begins to make sense of course at the
beginning we can look lightly at
explanations on grammar but we will
not retain much on the
other hand if after having read and
listened a lot and if we go over the
grammar books slightly not with
the intention of  remembering what is
there and wanting to take
it that's not it but that we will see that
with enough words its
explanations will we must
naturally started to stay from one
in our heads
good we can ask ourselves  but what
does it mean to know how to recognize a
word well there are people who read and
I have to
be able to use it
all the evils that I study but that's
not realistic  we will obviously know a
lot more words in a
passive way than we have used it is
normal and it is good like that because
the natives
they will use a lot of words
they know a lot more than us and
if we  don't have a
very large passive vocabulary we're going to have a
lot of trouble understanding what they
say and its words so
easy easy vocabulary little by little will
become an active vocabulary
and moreover it's not by looking
in a  dictionary even if we
remember the meaning of the word which
is not obvious because me
often almost all the time I forget the owls
but the words are by
listening to them and lille by reading seeing them
in different contexts that  'we're starting
to get a sense of the magnitude of 2.2 of
the meaning and what words are
used with elmo and so that's the
main job
my main purpose when I said
moor alleys is to grow
my vocabulary is  t number one it
's not that doesn't mean
grammar isn't important but it's
less important than vocabulary
thank you very much